what if I told you dogs don't care about
us at all before I got Murphy I would I
talked about getting a dog for like two
years straight I decided to just walk
into the animal shelter one day who you
was to me one next to the mom so I could
tell he all that young guys and like the
Shires
and within five minutes we saw Marty and
we signed the paper his I think I
remember one time like I just had a
breakdown and she just like walked over
and and like kiss my face and I was like
you know this is okay we call him the
joy of our lives I was in a wheelchair
for a little bit and having her sit with
me in my bed every day when I was in
recovery was the greatest comfort and
everyone I was really close I started
moving away one by one I never had a
chance to be really lonely because I
always had Louie with me so would you
say that you loved Murphy yeah yes I
love Ella and do you feel like Ella
loves you yeah definitely I think he
loves me yeah
what if I told you that there is a lot
of scientific thought that dogs don't
actually care about us at all what what
what are the details well we can get to
those
a little funky bad news comes in cute
packages apparently so says in the 19th
century naturalist Charles Darwin
travelled the world on the HMS Beagle
leading to the formulation of his theory
of evolution
Darwin later wrote extensively about the
possibility that dogs have rich
emotional lives but couldn't prove it
the true modern era of dog research
began with scientist Ivan Pavlov Pavlov
is most famous for his discovery that
dogs who had heard a bell and will give
him food eventually began to salivate
merely at the sound of the Bell even
when no if the food was present this
gave rise to behaviorism and the belief
among the scientific community that dogs
are merely robotic creatures who give us
a fiction not because they love us but
because they know it'll lead us to
giving them food ready do you love me
[Music]
looks away and so for a century is you
held dogs were not our best friends they
were just what one science writer called
con artists at the very top of the
profession simply but dogs did not and
could not love us
thanks a really sad because I love you
so much
or if you're a liar I'm hoping this is
not true though
feel like something is coming
[Music]
hi this is dr. Gregory Berns I'm a
neuroscientist in Atlanta Georgia and I
always wanted to know whether dogs love
us like the way we love them but of
course they can't tell us so I had to
figure out a different way to do it
I used MRI and trained my dog to go we
didn't MRI so I could look at her brain
and see what she's thinking and feeling
while she interacted with me and Prasoon
we had a group of a dozen dogs doing
MRIs and one of the things that we found
was that the reward center of the dog's
brain responds to the sound of the
humans boys praising them as much and in
many cases more than whoo itself and
what this shows is that dogs really do
care about the social bond as much and
in many cases more than just the
provision of food I think what many dog
owners realize is that they're amazing
creatures with kind of a depth motion
that goes beyond what scientists used to
think and that they are very much
capable of love but certainly in their
way and very much like we humans love
each other to learn eat did you hear
that
I think you hit me happy I feel like I
can sort of more freely say that she is
also my best friend now like I'm sorry
boyfriend but my best friend's my dog
I'm really glad that our feelings are
mutual
and I hope Louie loves me forever
[Music]